绝不让AI写一行代码
这套方法能把AI从一个不稳定的代码生成器
变成一个严格执行你架构决策的高级数字雇员
第一步调研
别让AI在聊天框里空谈
命令他深度阅读代码库
然后把学习报告写进一个叫research md的文件里
指定你要用deeply in great details这类词
逼他彻底搞懂
记住这个文档就是你的审阅界面
第二步计划审完调研报告
再让他在一个新的plan MAD文件里
制定详细的实施计划
要包含代码片段
记住一定要用独立的MD文件
而不是它自带的计划模式
这样你才能完全掌控
并且把它持久化下来
接下来是这套流程的灵魂标注循环
当AI生成D版plan AMD后
你直接在编辑器里打开它
像code view一样
用行内注释去纠正拒绝或者补充
比如直接写不对
这里用PATC不是pot
删掉这部分不需要缓存
然后把改过的文档扔回给AI
让他根据你的注释更新计划
注意是更新计划还不是执行这个过程
重复几次
直到计划完美无缺
当计划无懈可击
就进入实现阶段
先让他把计划拆成最细的待办清单
然后下载一条终极指令
全力执行
直到所有任务完成期间
不准停
准用any类型并持续自检
这条指令的威力就在于全量不间断
高质量的执行
此时你的角色从架构师变成了监工
反馈要极简
比如漏了某个函数
这个页面位置不对
如果AI跑偏
直接get it回滚
重新下达更精确的指令
你必须始终握紧方向盘
钦定技术站
守护核心接口
砍掉多余需求
所以这套工作流的本质就是
用持久化计划作为AI的记忆之矛
用标注循环完成思想校准
总结成一句话就是深度阅读
手写计划
疯狂标注直到正确
然后让AI像精密机器一样不间断执行
这里没有魔法
只有严谨的工程思维